it's that obsessing though it truly is
I've seen so many writers who will sit
there and they will go over the same
thing over and over and it's just not
productive at all right so you're really
okay we we can talk I wanted to talk
about once the draft is because that's I
think we've heard from a few writers
that some of them do like three to five
pages a day so forgive me because I'm
not in that space writing scripts but
how are you able to do 15 a day I mean
that's fact I think I think a lot of
well first of all I think over time you
just get better right so you know it's
not 10,000 hours once you put that in
and you become the expert in whatever
you're doing
you know you can recognize when things
aren't working you recognize when they
are working for me to do the 15 pages
you can't waste time at all on obsessing
over if you like the scene or you like
this line of dialogue it's it is this is
it it's on the page you move on and then
everything's about coming back and
refining it later but getting it out is
a much more productive use of time then
getting stuck and sort of that turmoil
of not knowing if this is good or if you
want to go this direction or whatever
have to make his decision and and move
forward and when you do that you tend to
get a draft done faster which gives you
more time to go back and kind of remould
that draft a lot of writers also turn in
their first drafts and I think it's
really important to never show anyone
the first draft to always go back at
least once and clean things up because
it just makes such a difference
well that was yeah it was curious what
happens after the four weeks you haven't
read it let's suppose you have a hundred
and ten pages or so give or take I'm
assuming then you're combing through it
well the 110 would be in three weeks so
that I would give myself that last week
to take a couple days off right so that
15 pages a day
what is that for a hundred page I mean
you only really need ten days
right to write the initial draft and
then the rest of that is going back up
and cleaning it up and moving your act
breaks and in tweaking dialogue and that
kind of stuff oh and so you then you
throw in the three days to let it
breathe for a little bit so you give it
some space
then you come back again BAM it's four
weeks and then you have a meeting with
someone that's not how it works yeah
okay interesting so four weeks you're
showing it to this person and what does
that process like um so I send it in and
it depends on usually if it's a very
first draft the producer is gonna read
it first
they need to make sure that they're on
board and you obviously when you go to
the studio or the network then you go as
a team with the producer so they are
happy with the draft so they usually
give you a set of notes first I
implement those notes and then once
they're happy then it goes to the
network or the studio and we get their
notes back so by the time they read it
we already know that the producers
approved it for budget and they like it
and so you've kind of got that person in
your corner to if there is something to
fight for like if there's a I guess if
they don't agree with I don't know
whatever creative decision you've made
the producer is already on board and
understanding why you did that and
they're sort of on board with you so it
makes it a more productive meeting also
to have that then just like a bunch of
different people giving random different
notes that's those are the worst and
I've had that experience too but it's
not it's not the best way to do it you
know it's better to kind of like go
through the process correctly because
then then the drafts get better and
better so I wonder if we can even go in
closer to a day of doing 15 pages what
time do you start what is that what is
it like doing those pages I usually I
get up early so I usually get up around
6:00 and I start writing right away and
yeah I mean it's I take a break for
lunch when I get hungry and otherwise I
mean I'm really just focused on getting
those pages done and that's it I don't
know I don't know how to tell you any
different yeah since the day and you
know it's a lot of sitting in front of a
computer right and so you it's 6:00 a.m.
you're ready like I get more done in the
first two hours of my day than probably
the last five hours of my day so you
know whatever I'm doing if I'm at the
gym it's a better workout in the morning
if I'm here working it's you know I'm
getting a more productive I'm getting
more
and so I try to take advantage of those
hours there's happened to be a morning
person right you know I get that and and
I know we've talked to other people I
think you have less distractions then -
whether it's just you know just knowing
you're up before a lot of other people
or whatever controlling distractions I
mean you can check email every 10
minutes if you want or check Facebook
every 10 minutes if you want but you
have to you have to force yourself not
to do that because that really
interrupts your ability to focus and
you're forcing yourself not to go back
and reread be right because then you're
gonna be stuck on exactly interesting
now was that always the way for you did
you go back and reread stuff and did you
learn I think I I think I developed that
over needing to be able to finish these
projects more quickly and find a more
efficient way to do it because I
remember when I was in college and
writing I would do this thing where you
know I would get obsessed with the
writer's block oh I can't get through
the scene this is holding me up and and
it's just it's just a waste and that's
fine when you're writing as a hobby it's
not really fine then either but you know
at least you can manage it when you're
when you have deadlines and you know
you're getting paid and people are
expecting scripts and there's a crew
waiting on you to do this so they can
shoot it yeah you don't have that luxury
anymore so you just find the most
efficient way
you